okay so i'm going to be honest yeah
probably 90 of the theories in this
video will be wrong
but there's a chance a chance that one
is right
and i'll finally win i'll win and i'm
gonna be carried down the street and
praised as a hero because i'm back baby
kevin spoilers is back now the final
episode of loki is right around the
corner
and i thought i'd do one more video
talking about what i think will be in
the finale
namely who the big bad behind it all is
i'm not gonna bother with a spoiler
warning as this probably doesn't need it
but if it's your first time here then
welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host paul aka yabrowski from
another loki
now let's get into the video okay so
judging by the comments over the last
five weeks
it's pretty clear that the internet
really want to see kang the conqueror as
the big bad
his name has popped up at several points
in every one of our breakdowns
and he seems like one of the most likely
candidates due to the amount of nods
that there are to him
laced throughout the show in the comics
kang actually worked for the tva before
he went rogue
and potentially we could have the
backstory filled in with it being
revealed that he was one of their agents
but that he overturned the place and
then decided he would streamline the
multiverse
so that all that existed was one prime
timeline in which he was the ruler of
everything
this would make a lot of sense going
over what we've seen in the show
and it's clear that the tva are an
oppressive group of fascists
that will stamp out anything that they
don't agree with in order to uphold the
sacred timeline
in episode 5 you could catch the head of
the living tribunal and in case you
don't know who this is
the character is a cosmic entity that
watched over the multiverse
and made sure that things were kept in
line thus kang taking him out
would make a lot of sense there was also
the castle which we know the mysterious
figure lives at
and this could potentially be castle
limbo from the comics which is a place
that kang hung out at when he was going
under the name immortus
his primary love interests in the comics
is ravonna renslayer
and the fact that she hasn't met him yet
seems to line up that they're on a
collision course to come across each
other at some point
it would make a lot of sense to have the
pair come together at the end of the
season
and it would keep the character in line
with how she's been so far
namely her loyalty to the tva there's
also the central timekeeper who bears a
lot of resemblance to kang
and potentially can create him in his
image to rule over the organization
add to this the kang logo behind the
avengers tower eliath
and even the colours we see when the
portal opens which are purple green and
blue
it all just seems to be heading towards
kang coming down the line
now shout out to eric vos from the rock
stars for pointing out that his home of
chronopolis
also has pyramids in it and these could
be seen in the void at the end
pretty much everything in the show seems
to be hitting us over the head with the
point that it's gonna be kang
and though i know many think he's the
new mephisto there is actually a lot
more likelihood that he'll be behind it
all
because we know jonathan mages is
playing him in the upcoming ant-man
quantomania film
now speaking of films i heard kang is
making a movie based on the tva
it's about time i haven't having that
because because the movie would be about
time yeah there's
there's a movie called about time and
the phrase
it's about time means means like you
finally did it
you son of a [ __ ] so really really good
joke that now moving on in one division
we did watch as the show set up not only
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness
but it also laid the seeds for the
marvels and potentially secret invasion
therefore loki could be setting up
several properties such as thor love and
thunder
and maybe the third ant-man movie so his
appearance would definitely be a welcome
one here
i think there's a strong likelihood that
it will be kang behind it all
and his use of mechanics would explain
the tva being robots
and while there's about 20 easter eggs
linking back to him
every five minutes however i think that
the more likely theory is that the
person behind everything
is actually a loki variant now this is
because the story of the show seems to
be based on the book loki agent of
asgard
and in that it was revealed that there
was an older version of the character
manipulating his younger self to carry
out things the way that they'd always
happened
this show seems like it's operating with
characters stuck in certain loops
and this entire thing could be one big
loop created by a future version of loki
to ensure that his past version
overthrows him and ends up taking over
the tva
seats like this were sewn as early as
episode 1 and the devil in the stained
glass imagery which
was referencing loki could be setting
out how he or she
is the devil behind it all i think it
would be absolutely incredible if we got
to the castle to see richard e graham
playing the character
after we watched a version of him die
last week this entire ordeal could be a
rite of passage for loki
to make sure he ascends to becoming the
ruler of the tva
and that just makes a lot of sense to me
now because of this it could also hint
towards
something about selfie though we've been
told time and time again that she's a
lucky variant
and that she has nothing to do with
sylvie lushton i still think it might be
untrue
if we look at the comics and who sylvie
is she woke up one day with mystical
powers
and slowly over time she turned into a
hero however it was revealed that loki
had actually done this
and that he was manipulating her for his
own fun and games
potentially this old version of loki
could have enlisted sylvia into his
ranks
wiped her memory and enchanted her with
some new ones
he then could have sent her off to sort
of guide his past self to becoming the
ruler of the tba
whilst also making it so that he'd learn
the ability to enchant from her
even though she learned it from his
future self lots of tiny why me wibbly
wobbly stuff
but this would also explain why none of
the other loki variants have ever met a
female one before
i know we saw her childhood earlier in
the season but when you're dealing with
characters that can either have their
memories wiped
or false ones put in place then you
can't really take it at face value
from the trailers we also know that the
king loki version hasn't appeared yet
and potentially this could be what our
loki comes across when journeying into
the castle
now saying that i do think that this
clip will probably be used by the
villain to try and seduce loki with a
with a sort of c look what you could
have if you just side with me
you could have the best puns on youtube
you pathetic
loser oh something i'm talking about
someone else now
now this is something that enchantress
also did in suicide squad and as we know
loki has always wanted to rule over
asgard
so it would be something very tempting
for him though it could be a big reveal
i doubt that they'd show in a trailer
and instead i think it's a projection of
what loki could have
which is just a timeline in which he
rules everything however that doesn't
rule out the fact that loki could be
controlling at all
hell the show is called loki and it's
about dealing with loki variants
so a loki being behind it all makes a
lot of sense
it too would tie into the comics and the
general theme of loki
as in agent of asgard we ended with the
young version realizing that he didn't
want to become his older self
and thus he left to go on to do
something bigger and better
loki has always been seen as a stepping
stone to propel others to greatness
and thus him using himself to push
himself to something bigger
just makes a lot of sense you know
besides
tangent in order for clocks to work they
all need a hand
and i don't care i'm not apologizing for
how good that pun is yes it's a good one
now he's the person that i'm most
leaning towards and other theories i've
seen have been that it's dr doom
due to the castle and the secret
wars-esque landscape that's in the void
i've also seen that it might be ralph
boner which yeah i'd be i'd be very
happy with that
we could also stick with the
aforementioned loki theme but instead of
an older version of the main one
we get an older version of sylvie she's
pretty much the superior loki anyway and
it would be a big twist to learn that
she betrayed the original
when she was adamant that it would be
him now lastly is he who remains
the creator of the timekeepers who made
them at the end of time so that they
could start the next universal cycle
we already know that this rock in the
void exists at the end of time
and whoever is behind it all did create
the timekeepers
now if we look at the comics and he's
also a very likely candidate
but i don't know if it would be that big
of an ending if he showed up
he's never really been a villain he
doesn't really have anything in the
series that set him up
and i think it would be a bit
anti-climactic as he's kind of the
character that would just
talk them into keeping things the way
that they are now he who remains
was the last surviving tva member of the
previous universal
cycle so if they do bring him in then i
think it would have to be an elderly
version of mobius to really have any
true impact
he did promise to go and burn the tva
down but potentially he could have been
captured
had his memory wiped and then had been
forced back into his life of servitude
minus a jet ski i think that would be
the most impactful thing
and if they do bring in he who remains
for me that would be the best way to do
it
now we do know that season 2 is on the
way and thus i can kind of see this one
ending with loki overthrowing the ruler
and then taking the position himself we
will find out very shortly
but in the meantime i'd love to hear
your thoughts on the finale
a lot of people think that selfie is
going to die in the end which i think is
quite interesting but i just wanted to
cover the villain reveals in this video
but yeah the comments are yours to talk
about whatever you want to talk about
including how great my time jokes are
now we are running a competition right
now and giving away three mcu box sets
on the 30th of july
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the theories we pick the
comments at random at the end of the
month
and the winners of the last one are on
screen right now so message me if that's
you
at heavyspoilers on twitter if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of black
widow and all the easter eggs in the
movie
we've talked about the coolest deals in
it so definitely go give it a watch if
you have any questions over that film
now without the way thank you for
singing through the video i've been paul
i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you